let's go to five headlines
[Music]
all right let's go to um see what
headlines we got here number one the dnc
convention last night
we did our all-access watch party for
that hopefully you were able to join it
was the worst thing that's ever happened
to me
personally um i maintain though and i
survived for three hours
in one of the great feats of human
endurance of all time
the big headline from the convention i
suppose is that there was no real
headline they successfully avoided
headlines which i think is part of the
point here
certainly that's that is the the
strategy of the joe biden campaign is to
not make it into the headlines and i i
think they basically did that last night
anyway the entire focus of the
convention
really was or at least last night seemed
to be
that joe biden is a really nice guy
right
and that's why they told us he's a nice
guy again and again
and again and again and again by my
account there were approximately 75
slow-motion video montages or at least
felt like 75
slow motion video montages piano music
uh you know and it just telling us that
joe's a nice guy at one point his
grandchildren showed up
to talk about his favorite flavor of ice
cream and what toppings he likes
i'm not kidding that's how vacuous this
thing was and then joe biden got up
there at the end
and when i was half dead at that point
delivered a speech
all i could say is that the dnc is
thanking god or or
gaia or whoever the divine spirit
actually they had their
their uh their nun their fake nun give a
an invocation and she she prayed to the
divine spirit
but anyway uh whoever they're thanking
someone that the speech didn't have to
be live so i don't know how many takes
it took to nail the speech but the final
product was not bad
much to my chagrin you know no flubs no
gaffs
just a just a fine speech i don't think
anyone's gonna remember it
i don't think anyone remembers it now
but uh uh it was it was okay
there was there were a few moments of
cringe though uh
and i i think probably the most extreme
cringe
came from this so what did you think
about kamala harris's speech last night
it was tremendous i was so happy for her
i know me too she's fabulous i cannot
wait to see her debate our current vice
president mika pines
or uh is it paints
it's pronounced ponce i believe oh
some kind of weird foreign name yeah not
very american sounding
yeah that's what people are saying
strongly
well uh thank you andrew and please give
my regards to the gang
i will they're right in the next room
have a great night julia
thank you so much yeah all the comedy
bits were about as effective as that
the comedy was so lame and bad that i
almost thought i was at a republic that
i was watching a republican convention a
few times that's how bad it was
but then i remembered that i wasn't
because every speaker would carve out
some time in their remarks actually
about 75 percent of their remarks
would be allotted to informing us that
orange man
is indeed bad if you didn't know uh so
they did tell us that so that's what we
got joe biden is nice
orange man is bad that was that was the
message
let's go on here number two uh reading
now from the daily wire says the chicago
police department has banned protesters
from demonstrating on the block where
mayor lori lightfoot lives
ordering officers to arrest anyone who
won't leave
the directive surfaced in a july email
from then shakespeare district commander
melvin roman to off
officers under his command it did not
distinguish between the peaceful
protester lightfoot regularly says she
supports and those who might intend to
be destructive
chicago police have been blocking access
to the area using barricades and police
and riot gear
and lightfoot
told reporters on thursday that she and
her family have been receiving threats
daily she says i think that residents of
the city understand
the nature of the threats that we are
receiving on a daily basis on a daily
basis understand
i have a right i have a right to make
sure that my home is secure
right this is the same woman you may
remember who banned residents from
getting haircuts under threat of
imprisonment
and then went on and got her own haircut
so this is all par for the course
uh and in the reason for getting the
haircut the reason she gave
was that she needed to look good
which well no comment on that but the
point is that this is one of the biggest
hypocrites in the country
and the hypocrisy here really isn't even
funny or ironic or anything it's just
pure evil
in fact she lets rioters destroy
neighborhoods terrorize residents
do what they want but oh no not her
house not her house
can't come there and how does she
justify the double standard
you know in her own mind how do you
think she justifies it well i'll tell
you exactly how
she's more important than you simple as
that and that is
what she believes and that's how she
governs
let's go number three uh back to the
daily wire it says a school district in
tennessee is asking parents
to sign a form agreeing not to monitor
their children's virtual classrooms over
concerns that
that non-student observers could
overhear
confidential information the form a copy
of which was sent to the tennessee star
reads
quote rcs strives to present these
opportunities in a secure format
that pr that's protect student privacy
to the greatest extent possible however
because these meetings will occur
virtually rcs is limited in its ability
to fully control certain factors
such as non-student observers that may
be present in a home
of a student participating in the
virtual meeting the agreement goes on to
strongly discourage
non-student observation of online
meetings due to the potential of
confidential information about a student
being revealed
the agreement of course raised parents
interest according to the tennessee star
particularly given that the agreement
implied
items of interest might be being
discussed in classrooms without parents
knowledge
in an email to a parent sent earlier
this week the rutherford school district
said that they
they're taking parents concerns under
advisement
they said we are aware of the concern
that has been raised about the distance
learning letter that was sent out
the intent was not to prevent parents
from being involved with their children
during
distance learning but it was intended to
protect the academic privacy of other
students in the classroom
who are visible during certain virtual
class sessions yeah
um listen you know
you get a letter like that from your
school and
i i don't know how you react in any
other way than just pulling your kid out
plain and simple
they're confidential information
no no that there shouldn't be any
confidential information being shared in
a classroom
there shouldn't be any information that
you as a teacher
know about your students that the
parents don't know
but like we talked about last last week
and we've talked about before
you know they're just telling on
themselves here and what their real
agenda is so you just got to get your
kids out of the school i think it really
is that simple
number four the washington post reports
the kansas city chiefs said thursday
that they will prohibit fans from
wearing headdresses and native american
themed face paint
to home games at arrowhead stadium the
team announced the measures as part of
what it calls ongoing dialogue with a
group of local leaders from diverse
american indian backgrounds and
experiences
and recent consultation with a national
organization that works closely on
issues affecting american indian people
and tribes
so even though they're the kansas city
chiefs
and that's their mascot you're not
allowed to dress that way for the for
the home game
nobody can explain why this is offensive
it's just like assumed now
that if you were to dress up as native
american it's automatically
why what's offensive about it
if if anything it's it's honoring a
culture
and of course as many people point out
it's almost nobody
worries about this on st patrick's day
people are dressed up like leprechauns
drinking green beer getting drunk like
that's what you do
that's how you celebrate irish culture
to dress up like a leprechaun and get
drunk
nobody complains uh and as a person of
irish ancestry i don't complain either
it just doesn't bother me
but this somehow is offensive for
reasons that are not explained
okay five finally uh big news here it's
being reported that the band bts
has probably broken a record by getting
10 million views on their latest music
video in 20 minutes
10 million in 20 minutes
10 million people that's that's an
incredible number for just 20 minutes
now i have um
never heard of the band bts it's my
first time ever i don't know what they
are
i think they're a boy band uh but you
know i think back in my
back but go back to the old days you
know way back in ancient times
music videos were were aired on
and kids don't know this they were aired
on something called television
uh there were these things called
channels that you would go to
and if you wanted to see a video you had
to just sit and watch the channel
all day and hope that they played it and
there would be these things called
commercials
in between and it is very similar to the
experience you have
there's also this thing called a radio
you would listen to and uh if you wanted
to like make a mix table you couldn't
download it on the internet because it
didn't exist so
what you do is you take a blank
something called a cassette tape
and you put it in this thing called a
boom box and then you just listen to the
radio
all day and those of us who were avid
mixtape makers like i was
um it was you know this this would be a
this would be hours-long project if you
want to make a mixtape and get like
10 songs on a tape but you wait for the
song to play
you got your fingers on record as soon
as it plays boom you hit record
sometimes you get a little bit of the
commercial beforehand
in the in the recording but that's fine
too and that's how it worked back then
but now
and so if you if one music video was
going to get
10 million views cumulatively
it would take probably about 19 months
for that to happen and now it happens in
a little over 19 minutes so pretty
incredible but congrats to the uh
to the guys over there at bts big fan
big fan of theirs
i just decided that right now because
that's i'm in touch
with uh with the youth of today of
course well i hope you enjoyed that clip
from the matt wall show if you did go
ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content